big news actually related to the First
Amendment today to the government
limiting the speech of people and of the
press most of the time the right talks
about the First Amendment and it doesn't
really have anything to do with the
First Amendment YouTube banning people
over Terms of Service or private
businesses making decisions about how
their employees should behave while on
the job
those are not First Amendment stories
all of a sudden we do have a First
Amendment situation with Jim Acosta of
CNN and the back story of course now
memorialized in a video that has been
looked at like the Zapruder film Jim
Acosta asking questions of Donald Trump
during a press conference that led
Donald Trump to become displeased with
what was going on eventually a reporter
a White House intern rather coming up to
Jim Acosta and trying to take the
microphone from his hands Jim Acosta
zarm getting entangled with hers and
eventually that press pass
being revoked from Jim Acosta a lawsuit
was filed against Trump against the
White House against some White House
officials and most recently a federal
judge ordered that Jim Acosta's Press
Pass be returned immediately while the
press pass revocation works its way
through the legal system now meanwhile
Trump is saying number one that the
White House is writing up rules and
regulations for reporter behavior this
is important because of a ruling from
the 1970s which held that if the White
House is going to remove press passes
they need a specific process in place
that outlines how and why press passes
will be revoked I told you about this
case last week called Cheryl V nights
the judge timothy kelly who decided to
give a Casta back as press pass he must
be just some left-wing activist liberal
in the tank chillin judge who oh he's a
trump supporter I'm sorry he's a trump
appointee Oh gotcha a trump appointee is
the one who decided this important to
know there has been no ruling on the
case this is a temporary measure while
the case is being adjudicated and
additionally the White House has already
said
as soon as the judge's order expires
because it is temporary they will be
immediately rear evoking Jim Acosta's
Press Pass
I don't know ultimately where the legal
side of this is going to fall but I
relish the awkwardness I anticipate when
Acosta is back in there Trump's not
going to be able to keep his mouth shut
about it right and I know that nobody
has to call on Jim Acosta and maybe
that's what we see them do I would love
to see Jim Acosta back there on his
first day asking the exact same question
that caused all of this verbatim and
seeing what happens and this entire
thing understand there's two sides to
this on the one hand this is a story of
adults who can't get along because the
president simply doesn't respect the
press and Acosta knows how to get under
Trump's skin and he does that on purpose
that's all true maybe not everybody is
acting as adult as they should here but
that's not a surprise but we actually
have first and possibly Fifth Amendment
questions now about what was done and
all of a sudden the people on the right
that are always incorrectly saying
that's a First Amendment issue and this
is a First Amendment issue and you've
got this other First Amendment issue
over here none of which are actual First
Amendment issues they are silent about
the fact that this actually could be a
First Amendment issue what do you think
is ultimately going to happen with this
entire Jim Acosta press pass thing let
me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show one of the day's sponsors is
privacy dot-com slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the internet and one of the best
things
is how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link